[Music]  all right well baseball fans were  gearing up for a night under the lights  at the las vegas ballpark in summerlin  sports director chris matthews joins us  live in studio  and i'm hearing that this is not going  to happen tonight yeah it's really  unfortunate there uh  christian because the game was canceled  due to the vicious virus here las vegas  ballpark was all but ready to host the  nationally ranked arizona state team  along with unlv but as you can see now  the ballpark right here  it was all chalked up and ready to go  but kovid caused the cancellations virus  hit some unlv  players and they had to go through  protocols so the game was called off  now the game was sold out too that's  what's a shame here they had about 3 000  tickets people would already purchase  these tickets now  that would have been the largest crowd  that had seen the rebels play in a long  long time but  three weeks from thursday the aviators  will open their season right there  at the ballpark